sie versuchen sich zu retten auf die
dächer ihrer häuser oder das was davon
noch übrig ist verzweifelte menschen an
der ahr die fluten bringen tod chaos
zerstörung durchkommen kaum möglich
hilfe oft nur noch aus der luft
es ist eine katastrophe die mit den
wassermassen über rheinland-pfalz und
nordrhein-westfalen hereingebrochen ist
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und abend hinein der
sport nachher mit kristin die
hochwasserkatastrophe im westen
deutschlands bestimmt heute unsere
sendung wir zeigen ihnen die aktuelle
lage in reportagen vor ort wir schalten
live in die besonders betroffenen
gebiete und sprechen über den
zusammenhang zwischen diesen unwetter
und der klimakrise
es gibt mindestens 45 tote viele
menschen werden noch vermisst
ganze landstriche sind verwüstet
beginnen wir mit der übersicht betroffen
sind regionen in rheinland-pfalz und in
nordrhein westfalen zum einen teile von
sauerland und bergischem land und dann
auf der anderen seite des rheins die
region zwischen köln und der
niederländischen grenze besonders
schlimm ist es in der eifel und dort im
aartal allein im landkreis ahrweiler
starben mindestens 19 menschen mehr als
30 gelten dort noch als vermisst
kurschilgen berichtet es gehe nur noch
darum leben zu retten es geht nicht mehr
ums hab und gut der menschen so
beschreibt es ein helfer und dabei gibt
es wie hier im landkreis ahrweiler für
viele menschen nur noch die rettung aus
der luft in altena sind immer noch
dutzende menschen eingeschlossen schock
angst wut verzweiflung überall egal wen
man hier fragt
aus als wenn bomben wie weltkrieg
wasserstand bis brusthöhe möbel alles
defekt unterlagen versicherungen egal
was alles defekt mindestens 30 menschen
werden im landkreis noch vermisst
viele brücken wie hier in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler sind komplett
zerstört hunderte häuser überschwemmt an
der fast 300 jahre alten nepomukbrücke
im aartal zerschellte ein wohnwagen
die rheinland pfälzische
ministerpräsident in dreier- und
spd-vizekanzler scholz reisten heute
hier nach ahrweiler heimerzheim und
sicherten den menschen hilfe zu
wir sind bereits mit anderen ministerien
in der bundesregierung dabei
vorzubereiten wie eine unterstützung
aussehen kann
die wir den ländern den landkreisen den
gemeinden und auch den bürgern und
bürgern hier und auch anderswo wo das
wasser zugeschlagen hat und so viel
zerstörung angerichtet hat zugute kommen
lassen können trier an der mosel
stadtteil ehrang auch er musste
evakuiert werden
3000 menschen ein komplettes altenheim
und ein krankenhaus werden geräumt
auch hier herrscht der absolute
ausnahmezustand vorstellungskraft bei
ehrang an sich einen sehr guten
hochwasserschutz einen neuen hat der
erst vor fünf jahren komplettiert wurde
und wir waren uns unserer sache heute
nacht so sicher da kann nichts passieren
und auch immer wieder wie hier im ort
waxweiler bringen sich die helfer selber
in gefahr
um anderen das leben zu retten auch
jetzt noch sind mehrere orte im
eifelkreis von der außenwelt
abgeschnitten
die rettungsmaßnahmen laufen weiter
einen ort im aatal hat die flut geradezu
überrollt den ort schuld 700 einwohner
er liegt in einer engen schleife der das
wasser suchte sich den kürzesten weg
marion geiger jetzt mit mehr von dort
das in diesen trümmern menschen ums
leben gekommen sind es zu befürchten
wie viele genau ist jedoch unklar schuld
in der eifel in der nacht sind hier
ganze häuser vom ungeheuren druck des
wassers einfach weggerissen worden
vier häuser wurden ganz zwei teilweise
zerstört am nachmittag bilden 30
menschen als vermisst
es ist schwer zu fassen so viel wasser
habe ich in meinem ganzen leben sind
seit 34 jahren hier
wir haben hochwasser gehabt ja aber das
hier
mit weiter gilt der kleine ort liegt an
der ahr die gestern nach dem
stundenlangen heftigen regen zu einem
reißenden strom anschwoll mit
verheerenden folgen
hierfür gab es durch sämtliche augen
haushaltsgegenständen alles kamen
anschauen hat sich von der rüge
geschraubten apfelmarkt einen
riesenkrach getan
etliche häuser in schuld sind nun
einsturzgefährdet auch benachbarte orte
schwer getroffen
wir haben nach jetzigem kenntnisstand
entlang der aa vom bereich adenau bis
runter zur mündung und 100 gebäude die
teil oder komplett zerstört ist diese
zahl werden wir sicher noch korrigieren
müssen leider nach oben
im ganzen landkreis ahrweiler gilt
katastrophenalarm
unwägbar wie hoch die schäden sind es
ist mit sicherheit die größte
katastrophe im kreis ahrweiler seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg eine katastrophe die
wir uns in dieser dimension nie
vorstellen konnten die rettungskräfte
gaben an ihre grenzen mehr als 1000 sind
im landkreis im einsatz und reichen kaum
aus
bei diesem gewaltigen ausmaß der
zerstörung
unser reporter bobby cherry janistyn
schuld wo handynetz und strom
ausgefallen sind
er hat uns folgende beschreibung der
situation überspielt der ort schuld im
kreis ahrweiler wurde besonders heftig
von dem unwetter der vergangenen nacht
getroffen
der anblick hinter mir lässt erahnen mit
welcher wucht die wassermassen der durch
den ort gezogen sind einige autos wurden
mitgerissen sie liegen jetzt zum teil
auf dem autodach oder unter geröll
begraben
mehrere gebäude sind eingestürzt und
viele weitere sind einsturzgefährdet
die gute nachricht hier in schuld wird
niemand mehr vermisst also der verbleib
aller bisher vermissten personen ist
geklärt
trotzdem geht die suche nach vermissten
im umkreis natürlich weiter jetzt hoffen
alle darauf dass es nicht weiter regnet
denn das würde ein direktes ansteigen
des pegels hier zur folge haben
einige bewohnerinnen und bewohner
durften zwischenzeitlich zurück in ihre
häuser und wohnungen um zu schauen
welchen schaden das wasser angerichtet
hat
ich habe einige von ihnen fragen können
wie es denn aussieht die antwort lautete
nicht gut
robbie gereon in schuld auch das
bevölkerungsreichste bundesland
nordrhein westfalen ist schwer getroffen
insbesondere die menschen in der region
wuppertal hagen und im südwesten von nrw
dort sind viele straßen überschwemmt
anderswo laufen die räumarbeiten es gibt
viel zu tun
die schäden sind enorm nrw im
ausnahmezustand anselm stern
das ist die altstadt von bad
münstereifel heute am tag nach der
verheerenden flut nacht das wasser hat
ganze häuser mitgerissen viele kaputte
autos liegen auf völlig zerstörten
straßen
und der flut garantiert zehn jahre die
menschen sind alle leute die geschäfte
haben also es ist nur noch grauen vor
verzweiflung im land viele menschen sind
in den wassermassen ums leben gekommen
mindestens 15 alleine im kreis
euskirchen weiter nördlich die
kleinstadt altena handy aufnahmen vom
frühen morgen wasser schlamm überall
meterhoch in allen straßen mit
gewaltiger kraft kamen die fluten
gestern vielerorts in nordrhein
westfalen ist der schock groß genau wie
die zerstörung freunde von mir bekannte
und viele fremde haben von heute auf
morgen einfach ihr hab und gut verloren
das wasser drückt durch die wände in das
haus rein
die leute sind teilweise ohne strom in
den häusern eingesperrt tausende
feuerwehrleute waren und sind weiter
unterwegs in wuppertal versuchen die
helfer zu verhindern dass stromleitungen
weggespült werden die einsatzkräfte
überall hätten gut zusammengearbeitet
sagt ministerpräsident armin laschet und
verspricht unterstützung jetzt ist
natürlich auch hilfe des landes
erforderlich das kann man zur minute
noch nicht beziffern weil wir die
schäden noch nicht genau kennen aber wir
werden die kommunen die betroffenen
nicht alleine lassen das ist die
steinbachtalsperre etwa 40 kilometer weg
von bund enorm viel wasser der damm
droht zu brechen
er hat risse es gibt erdrutsche etwa
4500 menschen müssen raus aus ihren
häusern werden in sicherheit gebracht
nur eine weitere aufgabe nach der
tödlichen flucht nacht im westen von
deutschland
und jetzt live zu unseren reporterinnen
und reportern ariane gödel ist in
stolberg bei aachen ariane wie ist denn
die situation bei ihnen jetzt im moment
also die lage ist immer noch angespannt
und wirklich dramatisch die innenstadt
von stolper gleicht einem trümmerfeld
überall liegen pflastersteine rom
wirklich ganze straßenabschnitte hier in
der haupteinkaufsstraße oder eine
hauptstraße von stolberg sind auf einer
länge von über 50 metern komplett
unterspült und weggerissen worden dort
ist doch gibt's auch ein gasleck die
fensterscheiben der geschäfte sind
zerborsten
man kann richtig sehen wie die flutwelle
durch die geschäfte durchgerauscht es
ich muss leider gerade weg von der
hauptstraße weil der empfang dort auch
ganz ganz schlecht ist vielleicht liegt
es daran dass hier auch sehr viele
rettungskräfte auch in der luft
unterwegs sind
die polizei oder feuerwehr ist jetzt
hier am aufräumen
also die situation ist wirklich noch
noch sehr sehr schlimm und die leute
haben berichtet wie schnell das gestern
ging ein kleiner bach der eigentlich nur
25 zentimeter hoch es ist innerhalb
kürzester zeit angeschwollen innerhalb
weniger stunden also zwei stunden und
die fließgeschwindigkeit dieser
wassermassen war doppelt so hoch wie bei
hochwasser auf dem rhein
jetzt hat es gerade aufgehört zu regnen
es regnet nicht mehr aber die schäden
und die leute hoffen dass das schlimmste
jetzt hier vorbei ist und die schäden
die in der innenstadt sind wirklich kaum
einzuschätzen ist es wahnsinn was die
leute hier noch zu tun haben werden
ariane vielen dank entschuldigung und
weiter zu alexander hettich in
hagen-hohenlimburg wo das wasser die
wege herab geschossen ist alexander
haben wir die menschen eine vorstellung
davon wie es jetzt weitergehen soll ja
so ganz einfach ist das nicht zwar hat
der regen aufgehört die fluten haben
sich verzogen aber man kann an dieser
straße sehen welche gewaltige gestern
unterwegs war diese straße wird nun von
der öffentlichen hand saniert heute
abend sondern auch die bundeswehr komme
das ganze planieren damit die menschen
überhaupt mit ihren autos heraus kommen
aber wir haben mit den anwohnern und
besitzer der häuser hier gesprochen zum
beispiel der besitzer des häuschens
hinter mir aus dem jahre 1869
denkmalgeschützt liebevoll saniert das
wird von der hinteren seite vor einem
bach unter
bild und der sitzung gar nicht ob das
ganze haus überhaupt zu retten ist und
er weiß noch gar nicht wer das bezahlen
soll
fragt sich ob er da hilfen bekommt von
den behörden von stadt oder land also
die leute sind wirklich verzweifelt den
mann war das auch wirklich anzusehen
noch sehr viele offene fragen herzlichen
dank nach in nordrhein westfalen neben
deutschland sind auch belgien und die
schweiz von schweren unwettern getroffen
worden vor allem in den belgischen
provinzen und lüttich mussten tausende
bewohner evakuiert werden mindestens
vier menschen starben
in der schweiz hat es besonders luzern
hart getroffen weite teile der
innenstadt stehen unter wasser und in
rund um die schweizer sehen bleibt die
lage angespannt
und jetzt hat ja hier wieder bei uns zdf
meteorologin katja guten abend war das
denn jetzt was wir gesehen haben das
schlimmste ist das schlimmste vorbei
oder geht es jetzt so weiter da kann ich
jetzt aus meteorologischer sicht
tatsächlich entwarnung geben denn in
einigen betroffenen regionen von
nordrhein-westfalen rheinland-pfalz da
lässt jetzt der dauerregen tatsächlich
nach wenn es heute abend nochmal
dauerregen geben wird dann wohl nur am
alpenrand da werden dass 50 bis 80 liter
pro quadratmeter seien
das betrifft aber eben das allgäu um
vielleicht den schwarz war als sonst
sind noch etliche gewitter unterwegs die
aber nur punktuell und für kurze zeit
stark regen bringen
und dann gucken was hat er jetzt noch
aufs ganz große bild das war ja an sehr
vielen orten in deutschland bislang ein
sehr sehr nasser sommer
was ist da von wetter und was ist folge
der klimakrise in der unsere erde steckt
der sommer ist wetter aber dass wir
extremwetterereignisse wie die dürren
der letzten jahre die katastrophalen
bränden in nordamerika und den
anhaltenden dauerregen der letzten tage
immer häufiger erleben ist der
klimakrise geschuldet die klimaforschung
ist sich da komplett einig dass stark
wind band der jets in zehn kilometer
höhe der für unser wettergeschehen
verantwortlich ist kommt immer häufiger
vom weg ab er wird schwächer schlängelt
und windet sich und damit stecken tief
häufiger mal fest wie das tief bernd
solche blockade wetterlagen sind viel
häufiger als noch vor 20 jahren
dass der chat schwächer
hängt eng mit der erwärmung der arktis
zusammen klimakrise bedeutet also
tempolimit für den jet katja vielen dank
für diese erläuterung wichtige
erläuterungen heute abend und mehr als
100 katastrophe erfahren sie gleich nach
uns hier in einem zdf spezial und auch
online in der zdf- heute- app halten wir
sie in einem live blog immer auf dem
laufenden
die bundeskanzlerin ist im moment auf
besuch in den usa und zeigt sich dort
erschüttert über die nachrichten aus
deutschland
dies sind für die menschen in den
überschwemmungsgebieten entsetzliche
tage meine gedanken sind bei ihnen und
sie können darauf vertrauen dass alle
kräfte unseres staates von bund ländern
und gemeinden gemeinsam alles
daransetzen werden auch unter
schwierigsten bedingungen leben zu
retten gefahren abzuwenden und not zu
lindern sagt angela merkel in washington
in knapp einer stunde wird sie im weißen
haus von us präsident joe biden
empfangen als erste regierungschefin aus
europa seit seiner amtsübernahme auch
wenn es nach einem abschiedsbesuch
aussieht es gibt viel arbeit aus
washington benjamin daniel das anlegen
der stola war etwas holprig
sonst lief die zeremonie glatt die johns
hopkins universität hat der
bundeskanzlerin die ehrendoktorwürde
verliehen in ihrer rede hob angela
merkel hervor wie wichtig die von der
universität bereitgestellten daten für
die pandemie bekämpfung sind auf dieser
grundlage nicht zuletzt auch die
internationale zusammenarbeit zu stärken
ohne die eine solche globale
herausforderung wie diese pandemie nicht
bewältigt werden könnte
fast 16 jahre im amt 20 usa reisen vier
us-präsidenten und doch gibt es für
angela merkel noch premieren so traf die
kanzlerin am morgen die erste
vizepräsident in amerikas es geht bei
dieser reise um einen neuanfang nach
trump so soll es künftig ein gemeinsames
wirtschaftsforum und einen strategischen
rat geben in dem über große themen wie
demokratie oder klimawandel diskutiert
werden
weitere wichtige punkte ein härteres
vorgehen gegen china zölle auf
europäischen stahl
einreisebeschränkungen für eu-bürger und
natürlich der dauerbrenner die
umstrittene gaspipeline nord stream 2
die leitung die russisches gas nach
deutschland transportieren soll stößt in
den usa auf ablehnung deutschland mache
sich abhängig von russland heißt es ein
kompromiss könnte aber wohl bald erzielt
werden heute abend dann das dinner bei
präsident biden anerkennung für ihre
politische karriere und weichenstellung
für die zukünftigen beziehungen auch
nach der bundestagswahl
der vierte us präsident also für angela
merkel das verhältnis der kanzlerin zu
joe biden vorgänger war schwierig um es
vorsichtig zu sagen mit beiden gibt es
neue basis aber auch streitpunkte m at
wissen live in washington was kann
dieser besuch erreichen merkel und
beiden wollen das hören wir hier von
beiden seiten ein paar pflöcke
einschlagen für ich sag jetzt mal die
kommende regierung in deutschland in den
kommenden jahren eben nach merkel
und das tun sie mit einer sogenannten
washingtoner erklärung die wird den
schon genannten wirtschaftsrat
beinhalten aber auch ein strategie rat
die nennt man dann zukunftsforum da will
man über die großen fragen der zeit
klima russland china das verhältnis zu
diesen autoritären regimen natürlich
beraten die usa sehen beispielsweise
china im grunde genommen als bedrohung
an
deutschland sieht es mehr als eine
herausforderung die kanzlerin denkt dass
man darauf reagieren musste dem mann
versucht besser zu sein als das
autoritäre china auf vielen feldern
jedenfalls wird es hier keine großen
einigungen geben auch nicht in der frage
von nord stream zwei da arbeitet man
daran da wird es wahrscheinlich im
august dann eine gemeinsame erklärung
erst geben können aber der amerikanische
präsident ist sicher sehr neugierig von
angela merkel zu erfahren was man von
einer künftigen regierung in berlin dann
zu erwarten hat wer immer diese
regierung dann ist wer immer die
kanzlerin beerbt der soll sich so hoffen
die beiden jedenfalls daneben auf diese
washingtoner erklärung von heute
beziehen können matti wissens hätte
hervor schenken dankeschön
wegen des unwetters im westen
deutschlands hat unions kanzlerkandidat
armin laschet seinen besuch bei der csu
landesgruppe abgesagt in kloster seeon
sollte einen dissenz geklärt werden die
csu will steuersenkungen nach der
bundestagswahl tasche zieht dafür keine
möglichkeit
csu-landesgruppenchef alexander dobrindt
sagt jetzt es herrsche einigkeit über
schrittweise entlastungen von familien
und unternehmen schon lange streiten die
eu und polen über die justizreform dort
konkret geht es um ein kernstück der
reform ein kontrollorgan umrichter zu
disziplinieren
der europäische gerichtshof urteilt
heute das verstößt gegen europäisches
recht
warschau spricht von einem politischen
urteil das zitat auf politische
bestellung der eu-kommission gefällt
worden sei und noch ein wichtiges urteil
des europäischen gerichtshofs
arbeitgeber dürfen ihren angestellten
verbieten im job religiöse symbole zu
tragen ein kopftuch etwa aber nur unter
bestimmten umständen so müssen
unternehmen nachweisen dass sie
andernfalls nachteile haben zum beispiel
weil sie kunden ein bild der neutralität
vermitteln wollen
oder um soziale konflikte zu vermeiden
sagen die richter in luxemburg geklagt
hatten zwei frauen aus deutschland
nach dem anschlag auf ihn ist der
bekannte niederländische kriminal
reporter peter r de vries seinen
schweren verletzungen erlegen
das teilte seine familie mit de vries
war vor knapp zehn tagen amsterdam
niedergeschossen und lebensgefährlich
verletzt worden
die polizei nahm zwei verdächtige fest
der investigative journalist hat er den
vergangenen jahren immer wieder über
organisierte kriminalität berichtet
heute vor fünf jahren in der türkei
teile des militärs putschen gegen die
regierung der aufstand wird
niedergeschlagen
unmittelbar danach startet präsident
recep tayyip erdogan eine radikale
säuberungsaktion von der er sagt sie
treffe anhänger der putschisten
politische gegner unter ihnen
professoren lehrer journalisten werden
mundtot gemacht entlassen oder landen
hinter gittern
jörg brase berichtet
türkische fahnen auf ihren gräbern die
söhne ehemänner väter starben als sie
sich den panzern der putschisten
entgegenstellten
es gibt kaum jemanden im land der den
putschversuch gutheißt und verteidigt
aber viele die auch heute noch
fassungslos sind die einen waren muslime
die anderen waren muslime da haben
brüder auf brüder geschossen ich habe
vor angst geweint was sollte ich tun
auch meine kinder waren in dieser nacht
auf der straße der putschversuch einiger
militärs vor fünf jahren wird
niedergeschlagen es folgte eine
beispiellose säuberungswelle vor allem
gegen die mitglieder der islamischen
sekte die für den putschversuch
verantwortlich gemacht wird heute am
fünften jahrestag spricht präsident
erdogan von einem sieg der demokratie
jung und alt unsere ganze nation hat der
welt wieder einmal gezeigt dass die
türkei uneinnehmbar ist statt
demokratischer aber wurde die türkei
islamischer und autoritärer
oppositionelle werden verfolgt für viele
ist der jahrestag kein grund zum feiern
wir drehen uns im kreis man sagt wir
würden erfolgreich kämpfen aber wir
stehen immer noch auf der gleichen
stelle wie vorher
nach vorne gehen
fünf jahre nach dem putschversuch sucht
die türkei immer noch nach wegen aus
einer politischen und wirtschaftlichen
krise und jetzt zurück nach deutschland
und zum kampf gegen korona die delta
variante hat sich inzwischen auch hier
massiv ausgebreitet anfang juli wiesen
bereits drei von vier untersuchten
proben die delta mutation auf so steht
das in einem bericht des
robert-koch-instituts weil delta
deutlich ansteckender ist steigen auch
die infektionszahlen das robert koch
institut registrierte 1642 neue fälle
innerhalb von 24 stunden das sind 672
mehr als vergangenen donnerstag 32
menschen starben innerhalb eines tages
die sieben tage incidents steigt auf 8,0
vor den corona zahlen jetzt direkt zum
sport als christin und nach auch mit
zahlen olympia-countdown morgen in einer
woche beginnen die olympischen
sommerspiele immer mehr aktive landen in
tokio die leichtathletinnen haben noch
ein bisschen zeit so auch eine der
größten deutschen medaillenhoffnungen
malaika me hamburg die weltmeisterinnen
weitsprung 5 tage vor ihrem abflug nach
japan nimmt sich die zweimalige
sportlerin des jahres noch mal zeit für
die zahlreichen medienanfragen seit
ihrem wm titel in doha vor zwei jahren
mit der herausragenden siegesweite von
sieben metern 30 geht ihr fokus dem
großen ziel olympiasieg weiß dass ich
das kann und ich weiß dass ich sehr gut
drauf bin körperlich fit wie nie nur die
probleme mit dem anlauf timing
verhindern bislang bessere resultate und
einen sicheren anlauf sind einfach
weiten ja um die sieben meter einfach
wirklich nur noch purer zufall und ein
glückstreffer
offiziell konnte sie in diesem jahr die
magische sieben meter marke noch nicht
knacken im gegensatz zu weltweit sechs
ihrer konkurrentinnen dennoch soll in
tokio die medaille am liebsten wieder
golden glänzen
tennisprofi angelique kerber nimmt
dagegen doch nicht an olympia teil fünf
jahre nach ihrem silber in rio sagte sie
ihre teilnahme in tokio wegen einer
oberschenkelverletzung ab dadurch platzt
auch das doppel mit alexander zverev
razzia bei der tour de france beim
bisher stärksten team waren victorias
die französische polizei durchsuchte in
po das hotel wegen doping verdachts
gegen den rennstall läuft bereits seit
dritter juli ein ermittlungsverfahren
es gab keine festnahmen auch alle fahrer
sind weiterhin am start tagessieger auf
der 18 etappe wie gestern der mann in
gelb ddp
fast spielerisch setzte sich der 22
jährige slowene bei der letzten
bergankunft in den pyrenäen ab und
bejubelte nach 130 kilometern in luz
ardiden seinen dritten erfolg bei der
diesjährigen rundfahrt und bleibt
natürlich souverän
spitzenreiter christin dankeschön wie
geht es mit der unwetterlage weiter und
wie sieht's außer den regionen die vom
hochwasser verschont blieben
katja hornuf hat gleich das ganze bild
jetzt gleich nach uns ein zdf spezial
zur hochwasserkatastrophe mehr dazu
natürlich auch vom kollegen claus kleber
heute journal um 21.45 morgen ist hier
barbara hahlweg für sie da für heute vom
gesamten team wo immer das geht in allen
ein angenehm haben
[Musik]
guten abend innerhalb von nur 24 stunden
hat es bis zu 150 liter regen pro
quadratmeter gegeben und dieser regen
der schüttete sich hier besonders über
weststadt aus sie sehen hier wie dieser
regen dann im laufe der nacht weiter
nach süden gezogen ist und deutschland
verlassen hat heute über tag gab es dann
nur noch schauer und einzelne gewitter
sie sehen hier keinen dauerregen er also
keine flächige blaue farbe und so wird
es auch in der nacht noch einige schauer
und gewitter geben dauerregen droht aber
wirklich nur noch am alpenrand im allgäu
da können bis morgen früh noch mal 60
bis 80 liter zusammenkommen
die temperaturen heute nacht sinken auf
18 grad an der ostsee und bis 11 grad am
alpenrand und morgen liegen die werte in
der nordosthälfte bei 27 bis 29 grad
sonst bleibt es bei 18 bis 24 grad
kühler
morgen gibt's auch freundliches wetter
an der donau zum beispiel und auch an
den küsten sowie im westen deutschlands
sonst noch einige schauer und gewitter
unterwegs die sind aber wohl nicht mehr
mit unwetter verbunden und am samstag
gewitter das vor allen dingen auch im
osten am sonntag nur noch in
südostbayern und dann beruhigt sich das
wetter tatsächlich guten abend